[Music]
so hello everyone all right everyone's
here looking for a shrinking production
instance we're going to talk about how
to keep outages from affecting your
users and keeping them happy and keeping
everyone happy so whenever you go to a
talk you generally want to know you know
who is this person and why should I
spend an hour listening to them so who
is Mike Taylor
well he's me I spent a decade or so
building architectures and services for
our companies large and small and then I
got interested in this newfangled thing
called DevOps so I came on board at at
Google as an SRE and I've been an SRE on
call for a Google cloud for about three
years now and in those three years I
think I found more about preparing for
mitigating and avoiding production
incidents I had in my entire previous
career so I'm here with you today to
share some the best things I've learned
about production incidents or as we
usually call them outages and how to
shrink them but first it's important to
cover why I'm talking about production
incidents and how to shrink them the
head of Google cloud customer
reliability engineering Dave ryntsyn'
who you may have seen walking around
here he always says that reliability is
your most important feature of any
service users may not notice when you
have it but boy do they notice when you
don't have it every time your service
has an outage you burn away some of your
users good will do this too often and
your service will be too frustrating to
use and your users will go somewhere
else if you want to keep your users even
if they're purely internal to your own
company reliability is key and it's
definitely not free reliability takes a
lot of work and I've not even heard of a
2/9 service like just 99 percent
availability not even that stays up
without constant engineering effort so
that's what we're gonna talk about today
what you can do to keep things up and
happy
so we've already established user
happiness is important let's graph it
across the time line of an incident so
your service has a level of reliability
the border between the blue and the red
areas of the graph that's still kind of
blue that when you go below it your
users will be unhappy in some sense does
anyone know what this level is called
get out there have you heard of it I'm
sure we've mentioned it every day close
that
SLO that's right your service level
objective five points to Gryffindor
that's an S just a little bit off the
screen there now usually the further
below the further below your SLO that
you go the unhappier your users become
above the target level for your SLO and
this is really the amazing part your
users become indifferent to your
reliability you can be hovering just
above the red or way up at the top of
the graph and your users just don't
perceive any real difference at least in
the long run I mean you're not gonna
stop having problems and users will
still see those blips but as long as on
average you're above that level then
your users won't feel like it's that bad
of a deal so the blue area up there that
represents your error budget when people
say don't sweat the small stuff the
small stuff is what fits up there in
your air budget you can use it like what
Gary was just talking about for fault
injection this is where you do your
testing when you're still up in that
blue area that's what you can use it for
but that's kind of a different topic
from what I'll be talking about I'm
focusing today on keeping you out of the
red so what's happening in this graph
well not much yet let's say it's the
user Happiness graph for a chat app
because google loves chat apps and we
love building graphs for chat apps so we
start off nice and high in the blue
region when BAM an outage begins
maybe the release we just pushed is
overloading a dependency maybe some
developer added a long statement to a
hot path and Iowa's blocking you know
something bad happened and it's getting
worse
now the sre is on call for this service
are blissfully unaware that anything is
wrong at this point in fact they just
went out to lunch as usual in the
meantime though your users are starting
to get a little annoyed but their
patience hasn't run out yet once enough
errors have accumulated the alerting
system decides it's time to page the
on-call who checks her phone acts the
page stuffs a little more food into her
mouth and hurries back to your desk to
find out what's going on now this is a
particularly bad outage so we're
starting to dip below our SLO and if you
check online maybe you'll start seeing a
few complaints pop up here and there so
it takes some time for the on caller to
figure out what's wrong but they figure
it out they mitigate the problem and
they're your server starts running
reliably again so now your users are
starting to forget about the outage you
know it was bad but they got through it
and now things are okay and the longer
it stays okay the better they're gonna
feel about it but you know it never
stays that way and once you have another
outage then you might take another hit
now of course you want your users to
have the best experience so let's look
at this graph and break it down to the
parts you can improve you want to
minimize your time to detect this part
and the time to repair this part while
maximizing the time between failures now
that's all pretty obvious but think
about how this graph changes if the time
to detect or the time to repair was
shorter or if the slope of the graph
during the outage were less steep or if
you had longer to recover before the
next outage began you'd have much less
danger of dipping back into the red this
is what I mean by shrinking here if you
reduce the duration impact and frequency
of production incidents it helps keep
your users out of the unhappy red zone
so how'd much how do you know how much
to invest for improving each phase which
phase do you target first and where do
you get the data for analysis so three
is a magic number right these three
things underpin everything I'm going to
talk about today number one of course
you've heard a lot about these s ellos
you have to create and maintain s ellos
for your service they're the base of
spirit era budgets they define the
desired measurable reliability of your
service and they affect the entire
incident cycle because they tell you
when something is bad and more
importantly they tell you how bad it is
number two is post mortems you have to
write post mortems those forums are all
about how to make things better the next
time so when do you write one every time
you Resta lo takes a hit write a post
mortem sometimes something happens where
you get lucky and you're s though it
didn't take a hit but it could have you
still want to write a post mortem then
because you don't want to depend on luck
to give your service reliable it's the
SRA motto you see it everywhere hoop is
not a strategy the reason we're talking
about post mortems here is because they
record what happened when it happened
and why it happens I'll be talking more
about them later but you know this is a
very fundamental thing that we have here
and finally if you want accurate data it
really really helps have a strong
blameless culture a blameless culture
knows that whatever you did there's
probably something better that you could
have done
you know everybody's had that feeling
you're trying to handle something you
hindsight is always 20/20 but you don't
have hindsight in the middle of an
outage whatever you do it made sense to
you at the time and you did the best
that you could if it's hard for you to
figure out what to do or if it's too
easy for you to do something
counterproductive it's the system that
should change you should not be held
responsible for doing the best job that
you could with the information and the
tools that you had
I blame this culture is essential so you
aren't afraid to reach out for help
during the during the outage and you can
be honest and open in the postmortem
this makes the post-mortem actually
useful as a learning tool I mean here's
the thing if you don't have a blameless
culture then you're living in fear of
what blame your primary motivation
becomes to avoid blame not to help your
users is to protect yourself to protect
your co-workers I mean would you really
dive in and try to find a root cause if
you think that the results of my
research could get someone fired you
know that's not the environment that you
want to live in that's not going to help
anybody so blame this culture a
post-mortem built on the blameless
culture and SLO is to underpin it all
these are the three fundamental pillars
so remember these as we're going through
everything else okay so you got you
wrestle those you know if you need to
shrink to keep your users happy and
you've got your blameless post-mortems
so you have a clue where you need to
shrink to keep your users happy now what
do you do to drink to keep your users
happy I mean you know overall what you
want the graph to look like but let's do
min on each phase and figure out what
kind of tasks we can focus on to bring
each of them under control
no-nothing I'm going to talk about here
is revolutionary I'm sure everyone here
is heard of everything I'm gonna say and
you know they're all important but what
I'm trying to do here is relate each
task to which phase they affect most so
that once you figure out where you need
to help yourself you can then look and
say okay these are the kinds of things
that we can work on and this is what's
gonna get it the best benefit to our
team what I want you to think about as I
go through the next few slides is how is
my service doing here you know how does
this apply to me where can I invest more
where is it going to help me most and at
the end we'll have a Q&A and we can go
deeper into whatever questions you have
I should really note though that even if
you don't already have a blameless
culture or post-mortems or even SL o--'s
all the stuff in this presentation is
pretty fundamental so you can use it as
a checklist to get like an instant
readiness assessment of your service
and they're all they're all need to do
it's just how much you need to do each
one and then you can use future
postmoderns
post-mortems to focus in on the ones
that help you most alright let's get
started so you're having an outage when
your error budget starts burning so fast
that if you ignore it it'll burn away
all the remaining budget you can see
there in the yellow box that slope is
definitely going to interact intersect
with the red really soon so that's the
condition that you have to fire your
alert on the time to detect is from the
start of the outage to in a person that
can actually work on fixing the the
problem is alerted remember as a person
on call for a service you can't even
begin to think about mitigating an issue
until you know it's there so some
proactive work here is required
you don't really don't want your first
post modem you really don't want your
first post mortem to say service died
nobody knew we lost a lot of money it's
not a good way to go
alright so we have another good rule of
three here for shrinking time to detect
first off need a good signal-to-noise
ratio for your SLI that's your service
level indicator but your SLO is based on
you know whether you have a problem
because of your SLI is good SL eyes only
move up or down when your users are
actively getting happier or sadder if
this isn't true for the SLI is that you
have you need to fix them since you
really only want to alert on problems
that your users actually care about so
make sure your SLI is map very well to
how your users are actually feeling how
do you do that well you have to have
some backup way to figure out how your
users are feeling of internet complaints
service calls phone calls from angry
customers it was something just tell you
that I'm in the red and they're calling
me that's a good signal I'm in the red
and no one's calling me maybe your SLI
is too sensitive maybe like you have a
lot of jitter in your SLI and you can't
use it very effectively like a lot of
people have like a batch process that
will hit their service really hard for
five minutes or ten minutes at midnight
you don't really want to have a bunch of
errors showing up at midnight for a
batch process that you control and have
it page all the people on your on call
service at midnight so maybe take that
traffic split it off to a separate SLI
or some people have SLI x'd that have
all errors who turn from a service
counts against the rest of live but for
hundreds 404s maybe that you don't care
about those maybe that's not a good
signal so
where we yeah so in the beginning for us
allies its most important just to have
something and then iterate iterate
iterate every time you have a
post-mortem look back on it and think
how did my SLI to teach me about how
what's actually going on in this in this
outage is it worse than what the SLI
said tweak it is it better you know go
back the other way am i measuring the
wrong thing go back and make a different
nests alive
all right the next is so you have your
SLI actually reading something you
actually have to get your readings fresh
so you're alerting system can do
something with it this means that you'll
actually get your alerts before
everything explodes hopefully when
company I've worked for generated all
their metrics from analyzing logs now
this worked out pretty well for them
analyzing historic behavior but it
introduced a level latency for their
actual alerts so we helped them you know
move it from a batch log processing
system to a streaming metrics collection
system that goes directly from their
service process to the metrics backend
and is analyzed inline and this helped
them get a lot of that latency out so
the final of element of shrinking time
to detect is the alerts themselves what
does it mean for an alert to be
effective effective alerts are user
focused sensitive actionable and
delivered appropriately now I'll go
through that one by one you want user
focused alerts that only fire when users
are actually being affected this is
where your SLO definitions come into
play like I said if your s ellos are
user focused then your slis will be used
for focused and your alerts we use are
focused they all fit together really
well if your base your SLI on some
indirect metric like CPU utilization
it's not a good signal it's a very low
signal SLI sometimes it means something
sometimes it doesn't you want your
alerts to be both sensitive and
actionable but it's hard to get them
both at the same time
Eilert too quickly and you'll be paging
at midnight for something that goes away
in seconds and your LUN colors will
start looking at it and you'll see it's
already gone away and they'll be annoyed
but if you learn too slowly then you'll
be wasting time that you could be using
to mitigate real outages it takes them
to analysis and time to find the right
balance it's also important to make sure
make sure that the alerts get to the
right person you know smaller companies
don't have as much of a problem with
this if they only have one on-call team
but larger companies that have multiple
on-call teams you need to make sure you
loop in all the right people as fast as
you can
if you can do any kind of automated root
cause analysis and automatically bring
those people into the alert then that
will save a lot of minutes as you're
trying to get things figured out
finally and this is important make it
loud use a service like pager duty ops
teeny Victor ops fire hydrant something
that sends alerts as a phone call or a
page don't just use email I repeat do
not just use email email this to be
ignored it's all it's good for I repeat
it is not good at all to use email the
time will come when the person on call
for your service has got to take a
shower or eat dinner or go to sleep and
very few people check their email while
doing these things so with these three
your time to detect will be in pretty
good shape
so shrinking time to detect was all
technical tasks shrinking time to repair
though is mostly about people policies
training and most importantly stress
management even if you've Alert super
efficiently what good is it if everybody
panics when you get the alert in my
opinion this is the most important
section to focus on
you'll always have outages they're not
going away you can automate fast
solutions to many of these but not all
of them you hire engineers because
they're smart and creative and they're
ultimately the best resource you have
for fixing the problems that slip
through the cracks of course they're
also the slowest mechanism you have for
fixing the problems but they're your
last most capable defense and it pays to
prepare them properly
so a quick reminder before we begin this
section an incident responders first
duty is to protect the user and the
users data during your outage keep your
focus just on that don't go and try
finding all the all the causal factors
it just doesn't help at that point so a
good response is a temporary failover
a version rollback I'm an emergency
request for more resources that's all
good
a bad response you know go into the code
debug it fix it check it in build a new
release push it out that takes way too
long you don't have time for this do
that later when the service is not
actively burning so what can you do to
improve your time to repair first you
have to train your responders you need
emergency procedures to find and test it
so that everyone involved can be calm
and productive during an outage you need
procedures that provide enough structure
so that it's all organized and people
know what's going on but you need them
to be flexible enough so that a lot of
ad hoc debugging and I'm impromptu sub
structures can take effect and don't
just train the people on call train
everybody who might participate in
Incident Response devs product managers
project managers even CEOs anybody who
might contribute and have to make some
sort of call and don't train them just
once instant response training gets
rusty
really really quickly to keep it fresh a
lot of teams at Google run weekly
failure drills we call them wheels of
misfortune because we choose somebody at
random and make them try something like
fix some sort of problem introduction we
call them volunteers but you know we put
that in quotes because they're more
voluntold what to do so they go and
they're given some sort of alert and
they they talk through the steps what
they would do and then another member of
the team
someone who organized the drill will
play the part of any external systems or
external teams that are contacting with
them a simple example could be an alert
comes in that users can't log into your
service what do you do and you go talk
through all the tools that you use all
the things you investigate and all the
people that you contact you can also
hold practical disaster recovery tests
where you actually engineer real
controlled outages and then mitigate
them this is a lot what Gary was talking
about in the last presentation this
gives everyone practice with actually
communicating with each other and among
other things test all your escalation
channels you can get the whole company
together to do a whole company drill
like this something that a scenario that
Google likes to run is pretend that
California had a major earthquake and
slipped into the ocean so Google
headquarters is just gone what does the
rest of the company do to continue
functioning and we do this almost every
year because it's important to figure
out how you'd continue working if your
headquarters just disappeared number two
here is that you have to write alert run
books some people call them play books a
run book is the first thing that an
caller sees when they get an alert you
need to write one for every alert that
can fire write down things like special
response procedures links to dashboards
what queries you would run in the debug
logs to find more information
everything is something someone who's
trying to handle the alert would like to
know I mean I'm not saying that you need
to know every possible cause and fix
before you even write an alert but the
run book should give you some sort of
clue for how to start the investigation
and where to go for help
now something I see a lot is someone
writes a run book but then nobody else
can understand it don't do this
when you write a run book even if you
think you're just writing it for
yourself
keep it brain-dead simple write it for a
version of yourself that just got back
from vacation and has completely
forgotten how to do everything this is
actually a good opportunity for a
failure drill give the run book to an
alert or give the run book given alert
for the run book to the to a volunteer
and see if they can follow it is there
anything that they needed to do that
wasn't in the run book add it to the run
book it's just way too easy to forget
simple basic steps in the stress of an
outage so next up you need to create a
pager SLO so this is different from your
service SLO
this is the policy for how long it can
take for the person on call to start
working on a page regardless of what you
actually set it to it'll help even out
your time to repair they'll become more
consistent and that's a good thing
but what do you set it to I mean it's
easy to think duh just start working as
soon as you get paged but it's not quite
that simple say you set your pagers SLO
to something short like five minutes
excellent your average time to repair
just went down but what's the cost it's
it's easy to meet a five minute page or
SLO when you're at the office but what
about the evenings the weekends if
you're on call you can never be more
than five minutes away from your work
computer grocery shopping
no way going out to the park for a
picnic with your family it's not going
to happen
I mean you can bring your laptop but you
have to think what's it gonna be like
trying to solve a real problem with your
laptop going through your phone and
going over a slow connection it's not
fun there are some teams at Google that
do actually have a five minute Patriots
alone but many teams find that thirty
minutes is more reasonable then give
your page or SLO as your jumpiness
factor how jumpy do you need your
on-call team to be I mean choose this
carefully it's going to determine how
quickly you get started on incidents but
it's also going to affect people's lives
in the same theme actually very much the
same thing you want to start to reduce
responder fatigue as you might guess
burnout is a real problem being on call
is a hard job to do if you want to keep
your on on Colors on the team that
they're on call for you better make
their happiness a priority you can
automate routine operational tasks this
takes a lot of the load off their
everyday life
we call this eliminating toil a classic
example of this is release management
how much of the release can you automate
so you don't have to babysit it and
click buttons every half an hour you can
get more people on the rotation so your
turn for on-call doesn't come up as
often at Google there's a general rule
for six people minimum on a rotation you
might not actually have that many sres
but if you if you're short on that then
pull in some devs you know some senior
developers make really good on colors
and remember you're never alone so if
the primary on call doesn't know what to
do there's always someone else on backup
that they can contact this is always a
fun one you get rid of an actionable
alerts you can tune them to be more
effective but maybe you can just delete
them I can tell you that there's no
greater joy in an S aureus life then
proving an alert is useless and then
going and deleting it
we always throw like a little
celebration whenever that happens and
finally you might be able to relax your
SLO s this can be your pager SLO so you
don't have to be so jumpy all the time
even when you're not getting pages or it
could be your service SLO I mean do you
really need all five nines
maybe not five nines it's hard to hit
maybe four nines three-and-a-half you
know anything that brings it down a
little bit and still keeps your users
happy will make life a lot more bearable
for the people that have to support it
but wait there's more and this one's
important too you need to make sure your
responders are empowered to do the job
that they're paid to do both technically
and politically all right what do I mean
by this I mean you should make your own
colors have authority during outages
give them control over the system that
they that they're that they have to to
fix you don't want the on you know you
don't want the outages to go on longer
than they have to because you're on
colors have to go call it the CEO and
ask for permission to do something or
ago and you know fine try something
that's really important then find out
access could access tonight and they
have to go and find out why their access
is denied it delays everything and it's
not good for your users and you also
have to make sure that everyone else
who's working on the incident
understands that when an on call asks
you to do something you do it the flip
side of this is that you need a solid
audit logging framework so everyone is
still accountable for their actions
remember blameless does not mean
invisible another way for you to speed
up your response is to improve your
recovery tools if you know what you need
to do right away but it takes forever to
get it done but maybe you need to work
on this you can start by writing tools
for fast roll backs because you know
that's the best thing the first best
thing that any innocent responder can
try to do is roll back the version that
just went out because that very often
fixes the problem or automated failover
when something goes wrong that
particular part of your application
can you just failover to your backup
somewhere this is very dangerous to do
manually you want to automate this as
best you can and this comes up all the
time in post-mortems when you write
about what can you do but you could do
better next time think about what tools
you've used and what processes can be
made faster
and you need good monitoring when you
get a page the first place you go is the
run book but the second is usually the
monitoring you want to see visual time
series graphs for all of your internal
metrics these are not the SLE lives this
is stuff like you know error rates the
backend services queue depth and memory
pressure you know all the technical
details of your system that give you a
clue to where to bring your
investigation next and finally you need
queryable logging like monitoring you
need it when investigating and alert it
to tell you the error details for what's
going wrong and if you ever can't get
the details this way you know say so in
the post-mortem so the devs can go in
and add the lines so the next time it
will be so bad you have to make sure
that you don't have too much logging
though every line that you log has a
cost and you don't want to overload
whatever system you're using on the
backend for logs management that can get
very expensive too
so try not to go overboard with your
logging you also need to be aware of
user privacy issues
you can't just log you know user name
and all the data that goes along with
that
talk to your legal team about this and
find out what you can actually record
and how fast you need to delete it this
can be a really big issue and it's
obvious but I still have to say it do
not write passwords to logs it never
ends well
okay so you've mitigated your outage
good job your users are slowly
rebuilding their confidence in your
service you want this phase to last as
long as possible right
at Google we found that become the most
common trigger of outages is a code or
config change so to maximize time
between failures just eliminate all
changes right well it might work for a
little while and actually sometimes it's
a really good idea like say you have a
business that gets almost all of its
revenue in one particular weekend maybe
don't make any changes during that
weekend why take the risk
there's no purpose but in general you
don't want changes to stop there are
always features to push bugs to fix new
hardware to support new threats to
counter changes however can be made
safer and that's what we'll talk about
here but first let me go back and what I
said a second ago you don't necessarily
want this to last as long as possible
there are some companies I've worked
with that are just laser focused on this
section they think just no outages the
best way to go is just no outages but it
turned out it was the wrong thing for
them to focus on and it's probably the
wrong thing for you to focus on - I'm
not saying don't focus on it at all but
do not focus on this to the exclusion of
everything else I mean what happens if
you go too long without an outage you're
on Colors get out of practice and when
you finally do have an outage and you
will what do they do they have to go and
look back at the procedures they go they
don't have the muscle memory to figure
out what to do and everything ends up
being much worse than it would have been
otherwise also companies that prioritize
time between failures too highly often
slow the release process down to a crawl
and this is bad for a number of reasons
it's bad for dev velocity it's debt and
it's really bad for response time to
market forces when things happen in your
competitor companies you won't be able
to respond as quickly in general it's
better to focus on shrinking your time
to detect and your time to repair and
just take this as you need it
but that being said most of us don't
have the problem of having too few
outages so we still need to work on this
stuff number one is our old friend the
blameless postmortem
right one after every incident to
capture metrics and analyze how things
went and most importantly you discuss
action items to make it better and also
most importantly make sure you do the
action items I mean these are just not
to be written and ignored make sure they
get prioritized very highly against the
other features that devs are working on
post mortems are the key to preventing
the same incident from happening twice
or at least making it better when it
happens again remember there is always
gonna be new kinds of post mortems and
you can't afford to let them build up
you should write your post mortems
collaboratively with everyone else that
is involved you hit all the different
perspectives and all different
viewpoints and so everyone can
contribute to saying this is what I
thought was going on and this is why I
did what I did it's not that complicated
and they sound hard but they're really
not bad at all it's just a fact-finding
document and a little bit of this is
what I was thinking if you've seen the
Google sre book online there's a sample
post-mortem in the back and you can use
that as a template next up is CI CD you
heard this about this early in the day -
there's continuous integration and
continuous delivery this is how you can
deploy changes with reasonable
confidence that they won't blow up and
fraud probably i mean sometimes they
blow up in a way but this will help them
become smaller and less impactful you
need to automate your tests unit tests
integration tests and end tests and
rerun them really often to catch
regressions at Google we may basically
run every related tests on every code
change and we simply block the change
from never being committed if it doesn't
pass all of our tests this is a high bar
to pass but it also makes a lot giving
us a lot of confidence that when we put
code out it's not going to blow up and
you want continuous delivery so you can
get your code out as often as possible
this way each release will be nice and
small which means smaller things can go
wrong
it's much easier for you to figure out
what is going wrong when there's only a
few changes pre-release no I want to
talk about something really important
with continuous delivery here and that's
gradual rollout dragable rollouts allow
you to discover problems and rollback
before all your users are affected the
alternative here is just shipping your
entire binary and putting it out to all
services at once this gets the new code
out there quickly but if there's a
problem you're now a hundred percent
down a gradual rollout will only affect
a few people at a time and you can
compare the error rates for those few
people against the control throw the
people on the previous version and see
if those error rates the percentages
increase and once you have a good
statistically significant number of them
you can say okay we're reasonably
confident this new release is bad let's
roll it back even though we haven't
fully rolled it out yet it saves a lot
of your error budget it makes that slope
of the graph at the beginning go down a
lot more gradually and that's a very
good thing we call this canary analysis
all this filters back to the dev side as
well since there's always two active
versions of the code in production you
need your data structures and all your
code to be both forward and backward
compatible why both forward and backward
because you may get partially rolled out
change some of your back-end data and
then roll back so you need your previous
version to be able to read the data
written by your next version and
vice-versa so whenever you make a change
make sure they can read up to two
versions back and whenever you're
expecting a change to be there and make
sure it's there for at least two
versions before you change it next is
about your service architecture overall
so what makes an architecture robust
your architecture is robust if it
continues serving your users despite
significant internal failures think
redundancy no single points of failure
graceful degradation this means reduced
functionality and when there's an outage
instead of no functionality when there's
an outage like for example if you serve
some data gathered from some back-end
and that back-end goes down the page
that you splay to users can still
successfully be shown to users but maybe
with stale data or maybe just not
without that particular piece of data
make sure you write your cert your up
your user facing code such that it can
handle partial completions from the
backends and finally chaos engineering
you hear about this a lot nowadays now I
want to say I don't really like this
name and Gary said this before too we're
not trying to create chaos we're trying
to create resilience
you know whenever you see the word chaos
engineering think resilience engineering
anyway why use it
it's so you can find problems under
controlled conditions so you don't find
them in uncontrolled conditions if you
think your architecture is robust poke
it and verify when I talked before about
disaster recovery training or testing it
was for training the people but you can
also use it to test the systems this way
and the cool thing is it can all be
automated just write a test to break
something in production
and what do you expect you expect that
nothing happens at least to your users
internally you know things might be
happening all over the place you
automatically fail over you know your
redundancy kicks in this is all expected
but your service remains within your SLO
and that's the important part sometimes
it doesn't sometimes you find a real
problem so that's why you do this in the
first place so one of the most important
things to be covered today I mean pretty
much all of them are ignore at your own
peril but I think the most important
ones are the two at the top SL O's and
blame this culture this is what
underpins everything else you wrestle
those give you that common language to
say we're out of SLO we need to freeze
you the PM you told me in the beginning
what you need the user who's user
reliability to be and we're out of that
so you as the PM need to work with the
devs to say we need to prioritize the
reliability to get back up your SL O's
are your main four main force of
communication across different
disciplines and blameless culture so you
can make things better so you can
communicate so you can work together and
not be in fear of each other
[Music]